hey what's up my name is samuel leagues
i am
about to bid on a piece of land and i
thought you know what i'd actually
involve you in the process of how it
works
how do you buy from auction how do you
buy land how do you bid on properties
what happens so here's what happens so
basically this is the property it is
right now it's thursday the 11th
of february 2021. i've not been on this
yet i've just been
quietly watching um and
let me show you this what we're buying
that way so
well i say buying i doubt we're gonna
get it we'll see so
this is the property for sale right here
and you're buying this piece of
land with this property now this isn't
yeah this isn't like going to be a
massive site there's already planning
permission
to build another house so this is what
it's going to look like
it's a one and a half story bungalow
it was guide price of 115 000
and let me see if i can show you some
pictures
some photos so this is the land
that's for sale now when you bid on an
auction
that's it when you bid on an auction you
have to
buy it you can't then pull out you're
going to pay 10
down as a deposit then typically you're
gonna have about 30 days
to get the rest of the money to buy the
land so
how do you work out what how do you work
out how much you're going to buy this
land for
it's already got plenty permission to
build a house on it is it going to be
profitable
now i think it will be profitable so
it's in a very nice area i'll show them
that where it is
it's in a lovely little village um
i'll show you right now so this is where
it is
by the time you see this video i'll have
either bought it
or it would have sold to somebody else
so i don't mind showing you where it is
so it's not a million miles away from
where i live um i live in
buckinghamshire
around here property is probably i don't
know like an hour or so
drive from my house um
so anyway i've checked it out on nimbus
it's got planning permission it's oh oh
it just went up you see that it was one
two six five hundred and someone just
put an extra 500 bid on it
there's only 45 minutes left
so oh my gosh did that just pop up again
i've not been on it yet i'm just gonna
quietly see
what's happening now here's what i've
worked out listen
we don't know to the penny how much
things are going to cost
i mean i have spoken to my
cost manager and he reckons to build
to build that to build that
on that the land is flat there's plenty
of permission he reckons it's going to
cost about 160 000 pounds
okay maybe a tiny bit more with
professional fees architect quantities
quantity surveyor it might be about 185
000 pounds
so that's how much it's going to cost to
build now i know by looking
at other properties that are similar in
the area that it's going to be worth
once it's done about 460.
460. so that means that if it's worth
460
minus 185 that's going to leave you with
how much
so 460 that'll be the end value
minus 185 is 275.
so if i bought the piece of lamb for 275
okay and then i built one
eight five four i'm not going to make a
penny profit
so to buy that for 265 000 pounds
you would be an absolute number you'd
make no money at all you might even lose
a few quid
so 275 would be ridiculous i want to
make
how much money do we want to make on
this i'd say at least 120 grand
okay so 275 minus 120
155 now there's going to be some extra
costs there's going to be auction fees
there's going to be stamp duty so i'm
not going to bid more than 135
now am i going to get that accepted i
don't know
it's currently one two seven there's 39
minutes left
so i'm gonna bid one three five
and not a penny more in fact shall i
just bid something now maybe place
beard one two seven five hundred ah the
problem is if i if i bid now
if i bid now
it's just gonna kind of like make people
bid a bit higher a bit higher
i'd probably be smarter to just wait
until the very last second and then put
my bid in
the only problem is i've got a call
in about 25 minutes i'm gonna i'm just
gonna bid
confirm it one two
seven five hundred you are the highest
bidder
now i mean it's i'm sure it's gonna get
it's gonna get beaten on again
i'm sure it will so darwin if i want to
call
you're gonna have to bid for me you're
gonna have to bid for me
the way it's gonna be if you've been
above 135 you're fired
you're gonna be fired so i'm the highest
bidder right now
it would be nice and you can check this
site out
one three five listen there's not loads
and loads of profit in it anyway
you know i might make a hundred grand
which would be amazing
um so
i'm the highest bidder at 127 500. uh
let's
let's wait and see what happens while
i'm on the phone
i might literally be on the phone i've
got i've got a phone call
at like 25 minutes i'll be on the phone
i'll be watching it while i'm talking on
the phone
i've got a call scheduled with the bbc
so i'm gonna be on the phone to the bbc
i'll be watching it and then i'm gonna
bid and if it goes above 135
then i'm out i'm out so let's see what
happens
[Applause]
[Music]
22 minutes left i'm still the highest
bidder
although honestly people people wait
always until the last
literally the last 10 seconds and they
did so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to be i'm going to wait and
i'm just going to bid at the last second
oh 22 minutes in 22 minutes i could iron
another piece of land
don't wait to buy land by land and
weight
it's only going up in time they're not
building more earth
in fact the best investment on the
planet
is the planet we're the highest bidder
right now how long has left
how long he's left is 36 minutes
what we got on one two seven what have
you been why did you [ __ ]
because i don't know it was that stupid
what it's just not munched up with it
lord now isn't it
how much did you bid extra 500 quid ah
that's fine
so the reserves met is see 135 is cut
off though isn't it
135 yeah
because i reckon it's too high
considering there's half an hour left
everyone loves to jump in at the last
second
i'll let them do their thing but it
might be that everyone's got a similar
cutoff
point yeah
i'll say i think i think you'll make one
i think we'll make 120 on it
120 grand i reckon 120 grand it says
that there's 17 other people watching
them
there's quite a lot of people like this
also how many people are like us
who knew about it but have only just
gone on now
yeah i don't think we're gonna get it if
we do it'd be really cool
it's cracking a little deal what would
you say to anyone who's watching this
who's thinking we're gonna make 120
grand why don't you just bid an extra 20
round and make sure you get it and just
make 100.
a couple of things number one is
sometimes it's not worth the time
um because it's gonna be a lot of effort
number two is there's always risk
things can go over you need to have so
much profit in there and you know
if we want to get bridging or
development finance to do the work
that's a really big one isn't it yeah if
you want to get developer funds to the
works
if there's not 20 profit in the deal you
won't have to get any funding on it even
20 you're pushing it
yeah you really need 23. and lastly is
oh why would you just make 80 grand who
cares well no because there's other
deals that come out 120 rounds
so because of the reasons
see most people watch netflix we just
watch the countdown timer on auction
bids
how long's that 34 minutes uh you asked
me a minute ago i never
it's been a minute ago now it's 35.
should i watch it no
no anyway i'm going to shoot off
let me tell you something you have to
believe it first and then you'll see it
what people tell you isn't necessarily
true they'll tell you don't talk to
strangers
but then wonder why they're not making a
new business and not making new business
partnerships because you have to talk to
strangers
someone out with me one two eight
i'm no longer the highest bidder you
have been
out beard you must bid again to stand a
chance of winning
i'll wait until the last 20 seconds
thank you very much
oh geez i preferred it when he said you
are the highest bitter birth
okay 19 minutes to go i've been out bid
again now
now it's one two five hundred i'm
literally getting emails just to remind
me that i've been out beard that's what
they do here's the thing right
when you're at an auction in real life
it's not
it's even more it's even more so than
this but you kind of get like
competitive
you know because it's like you know to
win
you need to put a higher bid in you've
been outbid you get a bit competitive
even me i'm thinking like
i said 135 but if it when it gets to 135
the the ego and the macho nurse and the
wanting to win nurse could very easily
strip you from the actual well what's
the best number
when emotions are high intelligence is
low so
be really careful when you're doing
auctions even if it's online auction
that you don't get emotionally involved
into the deal you just need to think
look in the cold
day before i get emotional what's the
absolute highest i could but i could bid
now in my mind i already said that to
you i said one three five i'm not going
to book one three five
is one three five the absolute highest
we could go or could we go to like one
three a
or like what were you thinking is the
absolute max
because we haven't even seen it like
i was thinking
so it depends how long is that
17 minutes and it's on 1 2 8 500.
um
yeah well it's not even that cold i mean
it's 16 minutes to go it's cold ish
it's warm right now but it will be hot
well you know the biggest thing is man
what do you think i reckon we could
i reckon as long as it starts with a one
and a three i reckon we're okay
all right all right see you later so we
can go up to about one three nine five
hundred
ah ah he's going it's gone above
well the good news is russell did a
great that as long as you started with a
one and a three
it was okay i don't think we're gonna
get this
discipline your disappointment so that
when the day of success comes
you can celebrate yeah i don't think
it's gonna happen
it's already one three six five hundred
i'm gonna i'm gonna go up to one three
nine five hundred
i've changed my bit and i did it in the
cold like a day with the approval of
russell my business partner
and mentor so
oh man now i've got this call coming in
ella can help how is it yes it is
[Applause]
um
[Music]
imagine if i get this while i'm
[Music]
a few moments later so i've just
finished on the call the
site sold for a 163
000 pounds i i did say that to you yeah
you did yeah i said i reckon yourself
at 160. hey this is just it i mean
if you do that once a week you're
probably going to win once a month
once a month winning a start is not bad
but right now guess what's happening
i'm doing a winners on a wednesday
interview so i'm going to do this
interview right now
with my good friend nazi nazi
and i'll see you next time